merci d'être avec nous de ce logo et de
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénatrice centriste de la
Nièvre présidente du groupe d'amitié
francs Ukraine on va bien sûr longuement
parler de cette journée consacrée à
l'Ukraine mais d'abord un mot sur la
réforme des retraites puisqu'on l'a vu
dans le journal Elisabeth borne devait
la présenter jeudi la présentation a
finalement été reportée au 10 janvier
par Emmanuel Macron c'est un calendrier
plus propice selon déjà un mois ça
change pas grand chose sur le fond c'est
pas c'est pas une nouvelle oui c'est
peut-être plus propice je suis pas sûr
que les changements à la tête des partis
politiques soient vraiment tellement
essentiel mais bon en même temps que les
fêtes de fin d'année avec les
inquiétudes sur les coupures de courant
voilà bon ça permet peut-être de décaler
un petit peu le calendrier ça change
rien au fond du problème sur le fond
justement est-ce qu'un compromis est
possible est-ce que pour vous un report
à 65 ans sa nièce alors pour moi
il faut qu'on accepte tous en
responsabilité de d'allonger un petit
peu la durée de de des carrières la
difficulté à pour moi elle porte pas
vraiment sur la durée elle peut
justement parce que vous dites un petit
peu un petit peu c'est jusqu'où alors
quelques mois voilà mais 65 voilà bon
voilà ça me semble plus raisonnable mais
surtout c'est sur la pénibilité que ça
me semble compliqué parce que je vois
pas comment on va avec un terme pareil
c'est menti que c'est important tous les
travaux sont pénibles tous les travaux
comportent une forme de pénibilité et si
on travaille sur la pénibilité on va
créer des frustrations terribles d'être
maîtresse d'école c'est très pénible
d'être agent aux impôts c'est très
pénible vous vous avez aussi un métier
qui est pénible vous voulez très tôt le
matin vous terminez très tard le soir
vous voyez il y a pas que les métiers
physiques qui sont pénibles ça va être
très compliqué cette notion mais de
calculer de définir vraiment les
critères de pénibilité à mon avis c'est
impossible un dernier mot sur le
véhicule législatif c'est-à-dire par
quoi ce texte passera soit un projet de
loi Haddock soit par un texte budgétaire
qui permet au gouvernement d'activer le
49-3 est-ce que ça c'est une ligne rouge
pour vous bah surtout c'est le 49-3
voilà il faut quand même que les choses
puissent se fait dans faire maintenant
dans des débats qui soient réellement
respectueux de la démocratie et du
fonctionnement des institutions ce qui
n'a pas été le cas sur le budget sur le
budget de l'escu pour vous bon bah
écoutez voilà on va parler de l'Ukraine
puisqu'il y a beaucoup de choses à dire
aujourd'hui à Paris à l'initiative
d'Emmanuel Macron se tiennent une
conférence de soutien Ukraine et un
forum de la reconstruction avec 500
entreprises françaises on va faire le
point sur cette actualité avec Alexandre
tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Nadia sur le groupe
cette journée spéciale
Ukraine le président ukrainien vous le
dit merci a demandé hier au pays du G7
des livraisons supplémentaires d'armes
et de gaz pour le crâne
équipe déjà fortement l'armée
ukrainienne vaut le dix meilleurs ski
estime qu'il faut aller plus loin il
déplore l'avantage militaire de la
Russie dans les combats en termes
d'équipement je cite le président
ukrainien l'Ukraine a besoin de char
moderne d'artillerie d'obus ainsi que
des missings des missiles longues
portées et plus nous serons efficaces
avec de tels armes plus l'agression
russe sera courte et puis l'Ukraine a
effectivement besoin de gaz
supplémentaires pour passer l'hiver
alors que le pays est plongé dans le
noir dans le froid et que la Russie
bombarde le réseau énergétique ukrainien
depuis le mois d'octobre 40% des
installations essentielles de l'Ukraine
sont endommagées le besoin en gaz est
estimé à 2 milliards de mètres cubes
supplémentaires assurer vos
diverselenski hier aux membres du G7 et
puis il a également proposé un sommet
pour la paix mondial un sommet pour la
paix qui serait basé sur le plan
ukrainien qu'il avait présenté en
novembre un plan de paix en 10 points de
la restauration des frontières
ukrainiennes jusqu'au sort des
prisonniers des prisonniers alors pour
l'instant ce plan de paye a été balayé
d'un revers de la main par le président
russe Vladimir Poutine même si vendredi
dernier Vladimir Poutine a estimé qu'un
accord serait nécessaire pour mettre fin
à la guerre Nadia sur le groupe est-ce
qu'il faut franchir un cap dans
l'armement de l'Ukraine par les
Occidentaux livrer des chars par exemple
alors on a déjà donné pas mal surtout la
difficulté c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à
savoir très précisément ce que la France
a donné on nous dit lors des débats
beaucoup mais voilà j'ai on n'arrive pas
à voir
c'est un petit peu secret défense voilà
allez c'est un problème ça manque de
transparence où vous
c'est difficile de se prononcer bon on
comprend qu'ils ont besoin de beaucoup
de choses après c'est pas en termes de
quantité sur le cas dans ces arts on a
bien compris que c'est surtout
l'efficacité de cet armement qui était
vraiment un armement de haute précision
qui a fait la différence nous on est
allé avec le président l'archet au mois
de juillet les canons César ont été
ovationnés parce que c'est plus qu'une
question de volume c'est une question de
qualité de ce que ce qu'on leur envoie
il leur faut des il en faut et oui si on
veut qu'il y a la guerre il faut les
équiper maintenant on peut donner la
plus belle fille du monde ne peut donner
que ce qu'elle a mais justement parce
que en parlant de ces annoncé ça vous
avez entendu sans doute Marine Le Pen
qui dit qu'il faut arrêter de livrer ses
annoncés à l'Ukraine parce que ça se
fait au détriment de notre propre
sécurité vous comprenez ce discours et
est-ce que vous avez peur qu'il se
généralise alors le discours oui
évidemment c'est très facile de dire
voilà après après on sait pas non plus
très précisément ce qui nous reste lors
des débats qu'on a eu de dans
l'hémicycle on nous a assuré qu'on
n'était pas en train de se démunir et de
se dépouiller après est-ce que c'est la
sécurité de la France qu'on assure aux
frontières de l'Ukraine voilà c'est
c'est donc il faut continuer à livrer
cette annoncé ça dans la mesure du
possible après j'ai pas la formation
plus précise ce qu'on peut faire mais
sur le principe qu'on peut faire il faut
le faire voilà c'est important c'est
maintenant vous rencontrez régulièrement
vous me l'avez dit des responsables
Ukrainiens est-ce que nombreux l'envoi
d'armes ça reste la priorité où est-ce
qu'ils ont plein d'autres choses il y a
deux choses dans leur discours c'est
continuer à envoyer des armes faut pas
que ça qu'on baisse dans l'intensité de
nos efforts et la deuxième chose il
parle beaucoup de leur rendre justice
voilà c'est il y a le temps de la paix
il y a le temps de la justice et ils
sont déjà prêt maintenant à
amener accumuler la matière et des
témoignages parce que il peut c'est
impossible qu'à la fin de la guerre on
ne le rende pas justice sur ce qui se
passe on va revenir là-dessus sur
l'issue de la guerre et sur un éventuel
procès contre Vladimir Poutine mais en
termes matériels les armes ça reste la
priorité pour l'instant c'est ce qui
demande il faut gagner la guerre et
justement Alex c'est conférences
aujourd'hui à Paris elle disent à
mobiliser les donateurs pour aider à la
reconstruction Ukraine aussi mais oui
après la Pologne la Suisse et
l'Allemagne la France organise sa
conférence des donateurs pour
reconstruire l'Ukraine alors c'est une
initiative à la fois d'Emmanuel Macron
et de volodium zellinski qui
interviendra aujourd'hui en
visioconférence le Premier ministre
ukrainien Dennis Miral sera présent la
première dame ukrainienne également des
chefs d'État étrangers de 47 pays le
secrétaire général de l'ONU Antonio
Gutierrez à cette conférence elle va se
tenir en deux temps d'abord le temps de
l'urgence du court terme avec des tables
rondes pour et bien voir comment on peut
aider l'Ukraine à passer l'hiver sous
les bombes russes avec plusieurs
priorités l'eau l'alimentation la santé
l'énergie et elle les transports il sera
également question de la sécurité de la
centrale nucléaire de zapporijah
essentiels dans l'approvisionnement du
pays et puis deuxième temps de cette
conférence la reconstruction à long
terme de l'Ukraine l'idée c'est de
lancer un grand plan Marshall comme ça
avait été le cas après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale pour reconstruire l'Europe le
pays aura besoin de nouvelles
infrastructures d'investissements dans
le secteur du numérique de l'énergie
également de la santé dans cette
conférence sur la reconstruction 500
entreprises françaises seront présentes
pour et bien participer à ce chantier de
long terme signer des contrats alors que
les entreprises américaines et
allemandes sont également sur ce projet
et puis notez au final que les besoins
financier de l'Ukraine sont immenses
alors à terme pour 2023 ce besoin est
évalué à 38 milliards d'euros et puis
sur 10 ans le coût de la reconstruction
du pays est estimé à 700 milliards
d'euros Nadia sur le groupe ça peut
paraître un peu étrange de parler de la
reconstruction du pays alors qu'on est
encore en pleine guerre oui c'est
exactement ce que j'étais en train de me
dire à la question précédente c'était la
livraison d'armes donc
et en même temps on parle déjà la paix
si on parlait de la surdité vraiment au
stade de la paix on aurait plus besoin
de livrer des armes on serait à la table
des négociations et là on y est pas mais
sur place est-ce qu'on est déjà dans ce
temps de la reconstruction est-ce que
les Ukrainiens que vous rencontrez ils
pensent déjà cette reconstruction alors
moi j'ai pas beaucoup entendu parler la
reconstruction non c'est vraiment la
difficulté du quotidien la douleur les
parents de prisonniers les parents de
soldats les les l'horreur là pour
l'instant au quotidien c'est l'horreur
de la guerre et puis l'horreur du
quotidien parce que moi je me plains
hier j'avais pas de chauffage dans mon
bureau mais c'est incroyable ce que ces
gens doivent endurer avec des enfants
des populations civiles là les
populations civiles souffrent
particulièrement parce qu'il est clair
que les populations civiles sont visées
et que la souffrance des populations
civiles est organisée c'est pour ça que
nous on n'a pas de question à poser à se
poser sur le camp qu'on doit soutenir on
passe soutenir en fait on prend le camp
des populations civiles qui souffrent
c'est pas les camps des Ukrainiens on ne
peut pas supporter que des populations
civiles soit intentionnellement mise en
des conditions de pareil souffrances
pourquoi Emmanuel Macron organise du
coup maintenant cette conférence des
donateurs est-ce qu'il y a aussi une
visée de communication pour montrer que
voilà la France est présente au côté de
l'Ukraine remarqué c'est très bien et la
preuve c'est que madame Hélène Sky est
le premier ministre arrive tout de suite
donc ils attend
ent faut pas attendre en effet au vu de
l'enjeu des sommes de tout ce qu'il
faudra organiser il faut pas attendre
que les
accords de paix soient signés on ne sait
pas quand pour tout d'un coup se poser
cette question c'est bien d'anticiper
les choses et la preuve c'est que ça
c'est fait en très peu de temps et tout
le monde a répondu très très vite un mot
peut-être sur la paix est-ce que au
final et bien il peut y avoir un accord
avec Vladimir Poutine pour conclure la
paix alors vraiment je suis incapable de
le dire la seule chose que j'entends de
la part des Ukrainiens c'est que il
parle pas de paie il parle uniquement de
victoire et c'est terrible parce que on
se dit que s'il y a un des deux pays qui
doit gagner militairement ça va nous
emmener encore très longtemps il y a
beaucoup de gens qui vont souffrir
encore sauf quand vous dites les
Ukrainiens ils parlent que je victoire
ça veut dire que évidemment malgré
l'horreur de la guerre et malgré ce qui
se passe leur moral est toujours là
après quasiment un an de guerre
maintenant on est à plus de 10 mois de
guerre leur morale je sais pas leur
courage en tout cas leur courage leur
engagement ils sont une force absolument
incroyable
voilà leur courage est là et eux malgré
ce qu'ils endurent ils veulent la
victoire et la justice comment ils
vivent justement parce que vous le dites
les populations civiles sont visées les
installations électriques sont visées
alors qu'évidemment il fait très froid
en Ukraine comment ils vivent ça les
Ukrainiens comment ils s'organisent dans
leur quotidien alors c'est incroyable
quand on leur demande ils répondent
normalement ça veut dire normalement
voilà c'est ça ils disent tout le temps
ça va ça va j'ai un ami français qui
était à Paris là qui vit à Kiev qui dit
les Ukrainiens ne voient pas tout ça il
ne voit pas ses difficultés voient pas
ses souffrances il ne voit qu'une chose
c'est la ligne de front et la victoire
au bout voilà ils sont incroyables ils
sont
galvanisés en quelque sorte bon
j'imagine que c'est très difficile mais
ils avancent ils tiennent ils tiennent
ils tiennent et s'organise et ils sont
d'une ingéniosité incroyable
c'est-à-dire ben parce que l'ambassadeur
nous disait qu'il y a des choses qui
sont détruites et le lendemain c'est
reconstruit on reconstruit on balaye on
nettoie on continue c'est ça justement
on parlait de reconstruction il y a
cette volonté de reconstruire tout de
suite après le passage des bombes russes
et nettoie et une étoile ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent ils ont que leurs bras
mais ils le font et ils arrivent à
bricoler un truc et puis ça fonctionne
enfin c'est incroyable on leur bombarde
leurs installations tous les jours et
reconstruisent voilà c'est c'est fou ils
arrivent à réparer alors chez nous quand
nous on a manqué d'essence je crois
qu'on l'ambassadeur nous disait qu'il y
avait un dépôt d'essence qui avait été
neutralisé 48 heures c'était rétabli
quoi et nous
on a
ça
et Alex parlait Alex parlait de la paix
tout à l'heure quand vous entendez
Vladimir Poutine il y a quelques jours
dire bah il faudra trouver un accord
est-ce que ça vous rend optimiste sur
l'issue de cette guerre ah bah c'est sûr
que moi honnêtement je vis pas en
Ukraine je suis pas galvanisée par les
mêmes arguments que j'aimerais bien
sincèrement que tout le monde arrive
très très vite à la table des
négociations moi je suis pas arc-boutée
sur une victoire militaire moi mon
objectif personnellement c'est la paix
si ça pouvait demain matin avant le 24
février qui marquera l'anniversaire de
cette guerre en Ukraine je suis
incapable de le dire par contre j'en
rêve tous les matins que ça s'arrête au
plus vite voilà c'est c'est vraiment
vous nous parlez tout à l'heure de la
demande de justice des Ukrainiens est-ce
que vous pensez qu'un jour Vladimir
Poutine sera jugé pour des crimes de
guerre ça vous paraît probable alors
c'est pas que Vladimir Poutine dont il
demande le jugement c'est il demande
vraiment la constitution d'une instance
d'une force de tribunal et que ils ont
recensé des dizaines de milliers de cas
de tortures de de viol enfin de choses
absolument épouvantables et ils veulent
que chaque russe qui a commis des actes
de cette nature soit jugé voilà et ils
sont en train de recenser dès maintenant
il recense il recense ce qui est
absolument atroce c'est un disciple mais
ils veulent absolument qu'on rentre
justice à chacune des personnes qui ont
subi des choses de cette nature mais si
lui-même Vladimir Poutine n'est pas jugé
est-ce qu'il considère que la justice
sera rendue ah bah non je pense que
voilà mais c'est Poutine et les autres
et on a bien fait oui non non oui oui
ils veulent que de manière pragmatique
est-ce que vous pensez que l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Ukraine sera un jour
restaurée ou est-ce qu'il faudra aller
vers un compromis négociation inévitable
moi à titre personnel mais mes amis
Ukrainiens vont me détester moi je pense
qu'il va falloir négocier sur des
frontières voilà qui qui sont acceptable
pour tout le monde mais je vais faire
très mal voir je vais mettre une cagoule
pour aller à la conférence aujourd'hui
après avoir dit ça c'est pas la position
des Ukrainiens
ils disent bon voilà ils sont rentrés
ils sortent ils sortent ils partent ils
reviennent d'où ils sont venus on
rétablit les frontières de l'Ukraine et
c'est terminé par ce que c'est possible
j'avais compris ça me semble compliqué
surtout qu'il y a il faut quand même le
reconnaître sur le territoire
ukrainien des personnes qui se centrent
donc voilà si on moi j'ai beaucoup parlé
des populations civiles c'est ça qui
m'anime il y a aussi sur le territoire
ukrainien des personnes qui se sentent
donc il faut prendre en la situation de
ces personnes là bon maintenant les
choses sont allées tellement loin que
les positions radicalement changé la
cohabitation pacifique c'est plus
possible maintenant donc voilà je peux
parler de ces populations civiles il y a
eu beaucoup de réfugiés évidemment
beaucoup de civils ont quitté l'Ukraine
avec un soutien notamment dans l'Union
européenne est-ce que vous pensez que ce
soutient sera encore là dans les mois à
venir notamment en France puisqu'on
parle de la France est-ce que vous
pensez que les Français sont toujours
derrière les Ukrainiens la même hauteur
de ce qu'ils ont été pendant ces 9 mois
les Français sont généreux et les
Français en plein de problèmes
franchement il y a des Français qui ont
des normes difficultés au quotidien et
vraiment on l'entend tous les jours
après il continue à faire preuve d'une
grande générosité mon sollicite leur
générosité pour plein de choses pour
d'autres Français qui souffrent moi je
dans le milieu associatif on voit encore
beaucoup de gens qui se mobilisent
beaucoup de générosité donc ça oui ça
fonctionne et puis évidemment la venue
hier j'entendais je vous dis quelques
mots madame zelenska qui est une femme
admirable de beauté et de dignité bon
ben évidemment des choses comme ça ça
anime un petit peu la flamme et puis
quand on voit les jeunes femmes
ukrainiennes qui sont là avec leurs
enfants qui se battent les gosses qui
vont à l'école qui travaillent bien ça
donne envie de continuer à les aider
évidemment justement le fait que c'est
conférences se tiennent à Paris à
l'initiative d'Emmanuel Macron avec
Madame zelinska l'épouse de volley
merzelinski est-ce qu'il faut aussi voir
un message politique de la part de la
France oui oui bien sûr oui oui la
France envoie un message politique fort
et ça c'est c'est une bonne chose oui
c'est c'est très bien est-ce que Manuel
Macron peut être encore un acteur
central de la paix entre Russie et
Ukraine et ben j'aurais peut-être pas
dit la même chose il y a quelques temps
j'avais l'impression qu'on était en
train en perte de vitesse mais le fait
qu'on organisait en quelques jours cette
conférence et que tout de suite on est
le premier ministre et Madame zellenska
qui arrive je pense que c'est un signe
fort et ce qu'à long terme au vu des
liens qui se sont renforcés avec l'Union
européenne entre l'Ukraine et l'Union
européenne est-ce que l'intégration de
l'Ukraine a lieu doit être et bien
développé voire même une adhésion un
petit peu le crâne à l'Union européenne
ou ce serait trop compliqué
politiquement on peut pas leur dire non
puisqu'ils on a engagé la démarche donc
si on est honnête il va falloir étudier
le dossier c'est un pays qui s'est
toujours trouvé c'est toute l'histoire
de ce pays complètement coincé entre
l'Europe et il se sentent européen et le
ce continent c'est énorme grand frère
russe voilà il va falloir probablement
trancher sur le sort de ce pays un jour
parce que sinon ça va continuer ça va se
reproduire c'est en plus c'était pas la
même chose parce que c'est ça finalement
la question oui alors quelle échéance
se faire très rapidement je pense que ce
serait de jeter de l'huile sur le feu le
processus ralent mais un de ces jours il
va falloir trancher quand même sur la
situation de ce pays
à tout à l'heure on parlera du projet
loi immigration voilà tout autre sujet
ce sera sur grand débat à suivre dans
une demi-heure en attendant on va voir
l'actualité dans nos régions on va aller
à Châteauroux où on retrouve Bertrand
CESAG bonjour merci d'être avec nous
responsables départementales de la
rédaction de l'Indre à la Nouvelle
République on va parler dans tout au
sujet avec vous Bertrand puisquière se
tenait un conseil national de la
refondation départementale autour des
questions de santé effectivement cette
réunion a rassemblée des professionnels
de santé des élus de tout le territoire
et des citoyens volontaires alors il
faut savoir que c'est un sujet
particulièrement important ici que ce
qu'est celui de la désertification
médicale dans l'Indre je vous donne
juste quelques chiffres entre 2010 et
aujourd'hui l'Inde a perdu 40 % de ses
médecins généralistes et près de 30000
habitants aujourd'hui du département
n'ont pas de médecin traitant il était
donc demandé à tous les participants de
se réunir en atelier pour élaborer des
pistes de solution pour cette
problématique et ensuite tout ça doit
remonter au ministère de la Santé qui va
compiler toutes ces pour en faire une
sorte de boîte à outils on peut dire
comme ça qui sera destiné à l'ensemble
des territoires et qui doit être
présenté normalement en avril 2023
du coup Bertrand ont émergé de cette
rencontre
l'un des objectifs majeurs qui ressort
c'est comment on fait gagner du temps
médical c'est-à-dire comment on retire
certaines tâches au médecin afin qu'ils
puissent passer plus de temps avec les
patients pour se faire on a ainsi
préconisé un de former plus d'assistants
médicaux et d'infirmiers en pratiquant
les infirmiers en pratiquent annoncées
vous savez c'est ce nouveau métier qui a
été créé en 2018 et qui est élargie le
champ de compétence des infirmiers qui
peuvent ainsi réaliser certaines tâches
en lui place des médecins autre demande
que les renouvellements d'ordonnance ou
les prescriptions pour les courses arrêt
de travail de quelques jours ou alors
pour enfant malade puisse être produite
plus facilement c'est-à-dire par
quelqu'un d'autre qu'un médecin voilà il
a aussi été question de l'hôpital et
d'encadrer le recours au médecin
intérimaires parce qu'ici on dénonce une
sorte de course à l'échalote à savoir
que les intérimaires vont là où les
hôpitaux leur proposent la meilleure
rémunération et cette situation et ben
elle a provoqué par exemple ici la
fermeture la nuit dans notre département
du service des urgences d'Issoudun et ce
au moins jusqu'au 31 31 décembre parce
qu'on n'a pas pu trouver d'urgence pour
remplir les plannings voilà c'est
quelques idées ici qui ont été relevés
durant durant la réunion mais il faut
savoir qu'un certain nombre d'entre
elles ont déjà été appliqués ici et que
les collectivités ont dépensé des
centaines de milliers d'euros pour
tenter d'attirer les médecins dans
l'Indre en leur rénovant par exemple des
locaux en payant du matériel médical et
même en allant chercher du travail pour
les conjoints des médecins qui
envisagent de s'installer et malgré tout
ça et ben ça permet pas de résoudre le
problème ça permet quand même un petit
peu de le ralentir mais pas totalement
d'où ma question madame la sénatrice ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il est temps de
réglementer l'installation des médecins
en privilégiant les zones soudées comme
c'est le cas ici dans l'Indre
je vous laisse répondre Nadia alors
merci au nom on vient de faire aussi les
conseils de la refondation dans la
Nièvre et puis ce que vous me décrivez
ces mots pour mot ce qu'on a vécu ce
qu'on entend etc déjà donc première
remarque j'espère que ça sert à quelque
chose que ce qu'on va proposer sera
entendu et surtout que la difficulté de
nos territoires sera réellement prise en
compte
en ce qui concerne la pénurie de médecin
parce que l'histoire des déserts
médicaux c'est compliqué de dire à des
médecins d'aller s'installer dans le
désert je vais assez attention à cette
forme de sémantique même si réellement
il y a bien un désert mais surtout la
difficulté dramatique d'accéder aux
soins l'équation elle est simple les
médecins pendant un temps ont été
beaucoup moins nombreux maintenant on en
reforme plus mais malgré tout on sait
que les jeunes médecins maintenant ceux
qu'on va former l'année nouvelle corde
donne à peu près deux fois moins de
temps médical entre la féminisation
ils vivent autrement
ils veulent pas travailler pareil enfin
bon voilà pas les médecins salariés
aussi donc on donne beaucoup moins de
temps médical logiquement il faudrait
informer deux fois plus mais on en forme
10% de plus donc ça va être de pire en
pire il faut surtout pas nous dire que
dans 10 ans après la suppression du
numéro exclusus ça ira mieux c'est pas
vrai ça va être de pire en pire donc
vraiment la première des choses c'est de
former beaucoup plus de médecins et de
les inciter à s'installer de façon un
petit peu musclée sur le territoire à se
répartir mieux sur le territoire c'est
pas une solution parce qu'il en manque
partout donc il faut pas prendre le
problème à la racine il faut en former
beaucoup plus et tout de suite et ça
j'ai l'impression que la coercition
c'est pas la solution non pas de faut
tout de suite former beaucoup plus de
médecins voilà parce que on continue à
foncer dans le mur en continu à
s'enfoncer donc dans l'immédiat mais
comment on fait dans ce que les études
de médecine c'est pas trois mois quand
même non alors déjà les études de
médecine il y aurait moyen de les faire
un petit peu moins longue à condition
que les jeunes étudiants en médecine
soient pas utilisés sous-utiliser comme
du la main d'oeuvre bon marché dans les
hôpitaux et que réellement il fasse il
travaille sur le terrain et soit en
ambulatoire on peut je crois que c'est
en Suède les études de médecine sont
plus court jamais exclusivement en
ambulatoire et là on utilise les
malheureusement les étudiants en
médecine pour faire tourner les hôpitaux
et c'est vraiment on le paye bon après
sur les mesures très rapidement vous
avez raison c'est la délégation de
tâches il y a pas de il y a pas discuter
mais à condition de payer les actes
alors juste prix c'est à dire que quand
c'est un infirmier qui vaccine il faut
qu'il soit payé autant que le médecin
que les infirmiers en pratique avancées
il y en a très peu qui se sont formés
parce qu'on leur demande de faire des
années le métier de d'études
supplémentaire ils ont pas de
rémunération au bout donc ils sont pas
incités à le faire les auxiliaires
médicaux c'est pareil la profession
était pas très bien définie donc il faut
que ce soit calé et puis que les
médecins acceptent la délégation tâche
parce que quand on discute dans
l'hémicycle parfois ça bloque du côté du
corps médical pour déléguer les actes
parce que c'est leur profit alors
certains disent c'est la qualité des
actes mais bon pour une vaccination et
puis quelque part on leur enlève des
actes donc après il y a nos médecins sur
le territoire qui sont débordés et puis
il y a le corp aussi qui fait que il
protège leur précarité parfois donc
voilà bon et puis il y a une toute
petite mesure dont on parle jamais c'est
que on a plein de diplômes étrangers
reconnus qui sont en attente de
traitement au Conseil national de
l'Ordre il y a des milliers de diplômes
qui sont en attente en instance au
Conseil national de l'Ordre à Paris
venant de pays avec la reconnaissance du
diplôme donc là on pourrait récupérer
quelques médecins après la coercition
moi je préférais que les jeunes de nos
territoires puissent accéder plus
facilement aux études de médecine parce
que plutôt que de les envoyer un petit
peu de force dans des territoires qui
connaissent pas l'idéal ce serait qu'il
soit issu de nos territoires et auquel
cas ils reviennent pour l'instant c'est
compliqué il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
s'interdisent de faire médecine il faut
rapprocher en fait les desserts médicaux
c'est la suite je dis les désert c'est
un désert de formation on a formé des
médecins en ville alors c'est pas
étonnant qu'on n'en voit pas dans nos
campagnes il faut vraiment nous à ne
faire on a réussi à avoir en
distancielle une première année de
médecine les jeunes ils ont fait ils ont
eu 50% de réussite en cours de médecine
cette année et ça c'est une belle
opportunité malgré tout faut avoir
attendre quelques années qui reviennent
mais on pourrait peut-être raccourcir
les études de médecine on a bien compris
merci d'avoir été avec nous la Une de La
Nouvelle République on va la regarder
ensemble Bertrand c'est une haie qui a
été planté par des élèves chez un
agriculteur plus de 2500 ans plantés à
Lyon c'est à la Une de La Nouvelle
République dans son édition de l'Indre
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
merci Nadia ce logo dans 20 minutes on
en parlait grand débat sur ce plateau
entre trois sénateurs sur le projet de
loi immigration puisqu'elle Isabelle
borne sera devant le Sénat cet
après-midi pour en présenter les grandes
lignes il viendront donc sur ce plateau
en débattre qui représente évidemment
trois courants différents mais d'abord
on va accueillir notre prochaine invité
c'est Jean-François Copé qui nous
rejoint